who where and when exactly tracing down
every single person who's come in
contact with a coronavirus carrier
surely that's something Olie Tech can
solve we must be able to trace every
infection chain we are working on an app
that can help us do that but that's got
civil rights activists worried there is
a real risk that these kinds of
surveillance systems will persist after
this phase of the pandemic is our
digital privacy at stake or could we
solve this crisis welcome to our Corbett
19 special here in DW news Monica Jones
good to have you with us our technology
has been a blessing during this pandemic
in many ways being working from home or
staying in touch with friends and family
and tech helps us keep track of the
virus now Australia's launched a corona
tracing app it records who's been in
contact with whom so they can be warned
if someone's infected China is using
apps to help prevent a second wave of
infections users scanned you our codes
in public places to share information
about their health South Korea has
developed smartphone applications that
help authorities track the movements of
infected people which are published
online and the government in India has
also launched an app that lets people
know if there's an incident of the
corona virus nearby one of the worst
affected countries Italy is also working
on an app that tracks people who've come
in contact with a confirmed case a
Germany is developing a system of
voluntary information sharing the word
voluntary may seem odd given the scale
of the pandemic but Germans really
cherish their data privacy after weeks
of partial lockdown however they're also
keen to get back to normal life and an
app could be key in getting there
getting the virus and going into self
isolation is a challenge for anyone but
data protection is just as much an issue
for many Germans do
this crisis that's hardly surprising
given the two periods of mass
surveillance in the country's history
that's why those behind the corona app
hafta guarantee data won't be stored
centrally essentially the app will work
like a kind of diary noting which phones
come close to each other and for how
long the phone's exchange key codes but
don't directly reveal their owners if
someone contracts the virus their code
is made available to other users they
can then check regularly to see if
they're affected all the information
stays on the individual phones
that's rather different to China a
country where surveillance is part of
everyday life
the large Chinese telecommunications
companies granted authorities access to
their databases at the beginning of
February allowing them to track
individuals movements thanks to
centralized data storage Chinese
authorities are able to see precisely
where those infected spend their time
and also see where groups of people have
gathered all of this allows them to
identify individuals as potential
spreaders of the virus but for
democratic societies that's unthinkable
for many people like here in Germany
anything alluding to surveillance is
unacceptable that attitude has led tech
giants Apple and Google to reject
centralized tracing apps and focus
instead on developing tools for
decentralized versions a tracing up in
Singapore for example centrally collects
the names and ages of its users but
Apple won't play ball and so the app
only works on iPhones if the user keeps
it permanently open as a result just 20%
of Singaporeans use it aided by big
texts new acceptable tools German app
developers could have a corona app ready
by June of a more I'm joined by Martin
de Gallina a postdoctoral researcher at
University in boham where he specializes
in data protection good to have you with
us please tell me how can a
Racing up insured data privacy on one
hand and limit the spread of the virus
yes first of all thanks for having me so
the data that we've seen around the
world over the last week's often track
gives us every movement to determine
where they have been and who they met
exactly but for contact tracing to work
it's very important to know all the
specific details of who you met and
where but it's only important to know
that you have met a person that was
later infected so it's not important to
actually know all the details but only
to know that you had met someone and
that's what what the current debate in
Germany is all about and in Europe and
that's what we what they're trying to
implement with the latest version
exactly this is why it takes a little
bit longer than in in some other
countries I mean I personally I have
nothing to hide at least I think so
but given the implications of this of
the app how foolproof is it I mean could
could the epicenter false info about
someone being infected so first of all
the app itself will not protect you
right because that's one of the problem
with with the corona virus is that you
often don't know that you are infected
somebody is infected so it's only the
app will only help to inform your
afterwards that you have met an infected
person and the other problem is with the
data security and that's what you've
also mentioned and that's why what
researchers are working on what a group
of researchers was working on at the
moment
to ensure that for example only health
authorities are able to say who is
infected it was not so or that you you
are not able if you use the app that you
can't edit the data for example you know
I could make a list of people that I
that I don't like and put them on the
list and say I met those people and when
I'm infected they all have to go to
current time right that's what we want
to prevent and that's why we're security
is important when because this is heaven
for tech savvy people but of course
given that it'll still take a while
until there is a vaccine would you say
that tech is key for us to get back to
an
life so this is a tough question right
so I think the app will help limit the
spread of spare off-the-rack virus but
overall things sometimes people have too
many hopes in this technology right
because it can only be one part of the
puzzle to to solve this crisis and to
limit the spread of the virus
after all we don't actually know whether
these apps will work because they've not
been tested for a long time in fact in
Singapore where they had these like this
for for some weeks already it didn't
have at all because the people were that
that we're when the virus is spreading
now didn't have any chance to do social
distancing and also their discussions
about how many people can actually
install this app because their technical
requirements you have to have a phone
that is not older than a few years and
that's not what everybody has in Germany
their discussion discussing that about
80 to 90% of the people actually have
the technical requirements so I have a
phone that could work and then you would
still need enough people that would
actually install it okay so while you're
telling us there's still a long way to
go but it's worth taking the time for it
to make it work Matt in Degel in there
from Rio University in in boom thank you
so much for your time oh they're so
still so many questions and many more
questions that you all have about the
corona virus now luckily we do have an
expert in house it's time now to get
some more answers from our science
editor Derek Williams can taking off
your shoes when inside help reduce the
transmission of kovat 19 great question
we're constantly hearing about how
infectious droplets that are coughed up
or sneezed out settle pretty quickly to
the ground where of course they could
end up on the soles of your shoes
now a Chinese study in a sick ward in
Wuhan found the virus on the shoes of
staff about half that
but that's a hospital in the midst of a
pandemic so it's kind of to be expected
in other settings it's going to be much
more rare I didn't find any documented
cases where shoes had been shown to be a
means of transmission but plenty of
doctors are saying that even if the
danger is slight it certainly can't hurt
to leave your shoes at the front door
when you come home especially if you
live in a household with small children
who spend lots of time on the floor
after all SARS co2 isn't the only
pathogen out there and you never know
what you might have stepped in how's the
pandemic now made Tsarskoe v2 more
common than other corona viruses this
question can't really be answered since
we just don't have the data but I would
say it's probably no at least at this
point seven corona viruses are currently
known to infect humans the list includes
SARS and MERS and then four strains that
that aren't deadly at all they only
cause cold-like symptoms most of us will
get those last four at some time in our
lives and and many of us will get them
repeatedly at the moment we've confirmed
a couple of million kovat 19 cases now
even if 10 to 20 times that number of
people have actually been infected and
haven't been confirmed we're still
talking maybe 50 million hypothetical
cases of kovat 19 worldwide but there
are over 7 billion people on the planet
and and how many of us have colds at the
moment a lot almost certainly many more
than have or have had kovat 19
does ethnicity play a role in the
transmission of kovat 19 in a number of
countries people from some minorities
are coming down with and dying from
kovat 19 at a disproportionate rates
people who are black in the US for
example are being hospitalized much more
often than would be expected if
ethnicity didn't play a role the problem
is is that ethnicity is is very complex
it encompasses not only your genes but
also a wide range of behaviors and
social factors like income in some
groups for example comorbidities like
like diabetes are more prevalent in
others people might be more likely to
live with several generations under one
roof those and many other factors can
all have an impact on both contracting
the disease and surviving it so the
answer is yes ethnicity is clearly
playing a role in kovat 19 transmission
but we're still struggling to understand
exactly what role
and Derrick Williams will of course be
back to answer more of your questions
tomorrow now as this tech heavy edition
of our show comes to a close let's take
a look at a community that shuns all
modern life and is still pitching in to
battle the pandemic over 400 Amish
families in the United States are u.s.
state of Indiana are working for a
start-up to make facemasks home sewing
is the norm in the community that mostly
rejects today's technology the company's
owner believes traditional social
distancing of the Amish lowers the risk
of contaminating the masks during
production it's also a way to generate
income for the community the sales of
homemade products drop with falling
visitor numbers